refer it for incredible performances
tonight oscar-nominated songs to refresh
the nominees are happy from Despicable
Me 2 music and lyric by Pharrell
Williams let it go from frozen music and
lyric by Kristen anderson-lopez and
Robert Lopez the moon song from her
music by Karen O lyric by karin Ellen
Spike Jonze ordinary love from mandela
long walk to freedom
music by Paul Hewson Dave Evans Adam
Clayton and Larry Mullen lyric by Paul
Hewson and the Oscar goes to Kristen
anderson-lopez and Robin Lopez for let
it go frozen
and Robert
people to ever upon an Emmy Grammy Oscar
and Tony which is referred to as the
Eagles
oh wow Thank You Academy and to our
fellow nominees you are all rock stars
literally we have so many people to
thank
luckily everybody's name rhymes idina
menzel Kristen Bell Jennifer Lee Peter
delle Vigne
Chris but Chris Beck John Lasseter happy
Oscars to you let's do frozen to Tom
mcdougal Chris Mont an arena Metzger
pester man Anderson no Lopez plan John
Groff Josh GAD mom and dad John boos
Eddie and our team back east and Kate
Brooklyn and last but not least our
girls Katie and Annie this song is
inspired by our love for you and the
hope that you never let fear or shame
keep you from celebrating the unique
people that you are thank you we love
you we love you thank you